the Joe Rogan experience at least then
though you have it life experiences to
pull from yeah you hear a lot of these
people when they're like you know some
people start in their teens and they
turned out to be you know the best in
the world
Dave Chappelle no but other people start
in their teens and I'm like have some
life first what are you telling jokes
about right you know like I mean like I
had like I had a whole career before I
got into Stan how old were you started I
started in 2011 so I was 26 25 26
what was your you we were saying your
career you were talking so I was I I
started in finance I used to work on
Wall Street I got a job at Bear Stearns
I'm so that's the wolf of Wall Street
for Joe I'm still trying to make it
happen but I I started Bear Stearns in
the summer 2007 and then it collapsed in
March of 2008 and then I stayed up with
JP Morgan for a couple years after that
but I wore a suit every day I worked
with like mutual funds and separately
managed accounts when do you think when
did you when when we were thinking about
stand-up were you thinking about it in
the beginning well so in March of 2008 a
bunch of friends of mine this is like
before
Barrett collapsed a bunch of friends and
I went to see a taping of SNL I have
always been such a huge fan that
afterwards I was like how these people
do this like how do you get here and I
google them and they all started in
improv so I started doing improv and I
did that for a couple years and then
even at my first improv class I was like
whatever I just want more of this I'm
like and then I eventually got into
stand-up after that around 2011 but it
was one of those things where I was very
much like you know like a very type-a
get good grades get try to get the best
grade in the class type of person and I
didn't really develop opinions or a
point of view mmm and so when I started
doing improv I was like you know like
you make choices and you you know like
and then more I got into stand-up I was
like yeah how do I feel about these
things like what do I think about them
and like really just like I don't know
that's how I that's really when I feel
like I started becoming a person Wow
I don't really had a personality before
that I wonder if I would have been as
curious if I wasn't standup if I'm like
how much of my curiosity is because I
started getting curious about things
because I wanted to be able to talk
about different things yeah like I I'm
definitely much more observational in
the world than I used to be but I'm also
I might be a little like darker too like
I remember thinking when I was a kid
like I thought about what my wedding
would look like as like a little girl
and now the idea of having a wedding
seems ridiculous like the idea of me and
like a big dress walking down an aisle
like there's none of that I could take
seriously but if you were gonna get
married how would you do it I would just
go to City Hall really yeah Wow and then
have a party or something maybe later I
don't I don't know it seems weird it
seems weird to have a party right after
cuz you're like let's see if this is
gonna stay have a legal contract with
someone especially you now because you
don't wanna that rose in bar Tom on oral
type deal you want to pay some dude off
ya know like imagine yeah I'm popping
for you you got some guy who kind of
like gums with you on the road becomes
your tour manager no way yeah well
there's the thing that would never
happen to me though because one of the
things I find most attractive is a guy
being really good at something so I
really good a pina tour manager
always has the best hotel rooms waiting
for you yeah it's like there's like
every time I go in it's set up exactly I
want to stocked with yeah
I think well that's the case with most
women most women I think like guys are
good stuff yeah yeah it's really it's
rare that you see like oh yeah I mean we
want I don't know a provider or someone
who's what you want successful jeans
yeah and that's really what it boils
down to make one attractive jeans women
want successful jeans or they want well
they won't someone attractive jeans too
they want
dominant genes like a big man big tall
man yeah good features good symmetry
yeah and all those things are genetic
it's normal you have been working on
this new joke about how women we like
we're attracted to the exact thing
that's the most dangerous to us like we
like those men and so we make more
dangerous men mm-hmm like we could
decide to just only mate with like short
soft boned men and make a whole
generation of like killable killable men
and women would be like yeah we're the
ones in power but we're not it's never
going to happen yeah but that would have
to be a real conscious decision that's
yeah against evolutionary biology it
would have to be like women have to be
like first of all we'd have to get women
to agree on something which is it yeah
no but then also like yeah you'd have to
be like no this is the law like a
reverse handmaids thing there's nothing
reverse handmaids yeah like we're gonna
out breed all the goliaths yeah all the
gorillas all the savages and barbarians
cut them off every once in a while like
a baby's born it's like at that height
like height and weight is too high and
they're like we've got to get rid of
this watch them hold them in the tub
yeah oh that's not wise cuz China's not
gonna do that China's not gonna use
CRISPR and develop Hulk babies we're
gonna need we're gonna need the might
we're gonna need the muscle dum dum dum
[Applause]